we are joined by Lakers beat writer
Tanya Ganguly how you don't tell you
doing great great to be back here you
are you excited to be covered that I
know the Bronco you got now what's going
on in LA everything it's always exciting
I mean ever since I started coming I
started coming this team in 2016 and
like it's been non-stop something
happening so now they've got two stars
again so we'll see see how it works for
them but what do you go from there
everybody some about the Lakers you know
need role players my personal opinion
you bring another superstar let them
fill in what's your take well we're not
sure if they're going to have the money
to bring in another superstar so that's
the first question I think they you know
they could be really good I think the
Raptors proved that you don't have to
have three superstars you have to have
even I mean you could make some
arguments about different guys in the
Raptors and how good they were but
they're really they're only superstar
was Kawhi so I think if they find the
right players they could become a really
good team a championship contender with
LeBron Anthony Davis and the right
players around them even if it's not a
max guy will the Lakers be able to find
the right guys I mean the way that they
constructed their roster last year it
didn't really work for what they were
trying to do so that'll be it's an
interesting test for them now they've
got a sticky cap situation can you help
break that down a mins where they need
some help from the pelicans to get it
you know get the money in time Anthony
Davis potentially giving it away so help
help right now they need the pelicans
are kind of in the clear on this because
the the Lana Hawks traded for that
number four pick that deal is going to
be executed on July 6 so there was an
extra about four million dollars they
could have saved themselves had they
negotiated the deal to be later in July
so now now that cuts off about four
million dollars they also are gonna need
some help from Anthony Davis in order to
get a Mac slot they're gonna need Davis
to give up his trade kicker which is
about four million dollars
[Laughter]
for the money you know reporters were
always thinking about ourselves but but
I mean he might you know I I you know
with the amount of money that he will
have anyway maybe he decides that it's
more important to do it's more important
to be able to fit another guy but
there's another factor too they're gonna
be trade on several of their young guys
that remaining young guys have already
traded three of them so once they'd if
they end up doing that if they're able
to convince Davis to give up that money
if they're able to trade away some of
their other young guys they're pretty
much going to be starting from scratch
with this roster it's gonna be Anthony
Davis LeBron James Cal Kuzma and then
from there their draft pick and then
from there it's you know they're gonna
have to just fill the roster with with
different guys so so there's there's a
lot of work to be done whether or not
they can they can open up that max slot
now speaking of young guys DeAngelo
Russell is swirling around the free
agency Tom that would be a crazy story
first he he goes then he comes back
potentially what what do you make of it
what's going on there's is that is this
even real I think it is it could I mean
I think that is a possibility
here's the thing with D'Angela Russell I
remember he was I was there for his
second year in the league which was my
first year covering the Lakers and there
were so many the Lakers coaching staff
really felt like he was they they
weren't totally sure about his maturity
level whether he could run the offense
what can't you know what kind of point
guard he could be and and so you know
you could argue it two ways on one hand
you could say they gave up on him and
they decided that it was worth losing
him in order to is worth losing him in
order to to go and get the cap space he
needed which eventually led to being
able to sign LeBron James there's that
angle of it but on the other hand a lot
of people really think that the player
that he's blossomed into here the way
that he plays now that that wouldn't
have happened had he stayed in Los
Angeles that he needed to go somewhere
else have a change of scenery learn a
little bit more about the league and
about himself and from what I've heard
there's the veteran
in Brooklyn I mean it's been a young
team to the veterans in Brooklyn were
really good with him and sort of helped
him helped him along and and that he's
become a very mature and you know on
some level this is obvious people mature
a lot from 21 to 23 I'm sure so that'd
be really interesting and I you know
tangible Russell's not really a bald
dominant point guard type of guy LeBron
James likes having the ball on his hands
he likes being the playmaker
so it could be a really great fit if you
know if if it ends up happening
wow that's intriguing Ryan Hollins here
on the Rich Eisen so we're here with
Tonya Ganguly Lakers beat writer to my
saying at Ganguly what do you make of
LeBron James I see he's been cool calm
and collected amongst all the
controversy seems like the everything's
kind of staring back towards his way
where all of LA magic you know steps
down
polenka is doing stuff genie the Lakers
around fire well the problems come what
do you make of LeBrons uh his demeanor
what have you seen you know he's sort of
taken a step away from it right now he's
not really saying a lot he's filming
Space Jam he's busy over the summer and
I remember the day that magic stepped
down LeBron was supposed to talk to
media that that day were like right
about at that same time and he ended up
canceling it because that shocked
everybody it took everyone aback it he
was not expecting and he just sort of
bowed out so I think what he's done what
he's done in this offseason is really
tried to stay out of it let it let it
sort itself out of course when he's just
because he's staying out of it doesn't
mean his interests aren't being looked
inward because rich Paul obviously his
job is to look out for it all of his
clients interests and he was very
successful in being able to get one of
his clients to LA so you know there's I
think his everything that they're doing
is part of the part of what they want to
do is make LeBron happy and I think
that's talked about sometimes as a
negative but why would that be a
negative I mean he's their star he chose
to come to this organization I think
it's reasonable
- it's reasonable to think that it's a
good thing that they're trying to keep
him happy so you know Jeanie buss is
kind of you know I don't know if she's
been under heat it's kind of hard to put
somebody in heat who's not putting out
certain energy is all the Lakers are the
clutch sports are they Rob pálinka Kobe
Bryant is this the LeBron show is this
the Rambis show who's calling shots in
LA is it that's a complicated question I
mean they have really given a lot of
power to rap linka and of course you
know I what goes on behind the scenes is
a little bit hard to say I know that Rob
was part of the reason Rob is in the
position that he's in is because of Kobe
could he was there on Kobe's
recommendation to Jeannie he Kobe has
remained a big part the Lakers are a big
part of his identity so he's remained a
big part of the franchise from that
respect how close do you think Kobe is
cuz we don't we don't see him we always
see him which you don't hear about him
he denies reports how close would you
say if you had to take a guess you know
to the situation well Rob palinka there
was one time maybe a couple of year ago
or so when I asked him how often do you
talk to Kobe and he said well he's my
best friend how often do you talk to
your best friend Wow
so I I would have to imagine they're
having a lot of conversations about life
and other things but also about the
Lakers Wow
Magic Johnson was honored yesterday how
tight is Magic you know obviously we
know he stepped down but I we just get
the feeling that he's never gonna get
too far away from the Lakers would ya
what do you read or you heard of what
magic I think that there are some mixed
feelings in the organization right now
about magic Genie talked about it
yesterday a little bit she said we're
gonna be fine she sort of pushed brushed
aside the idea that they're having
issues because of the way he's been
talking about his time working for the
organization but I have to say even
after he stepped down he was still
talking to people in the bill in the
organization he was still communicating
regularly with genie they went they sort
of did like a little social media moment
when they had dinner and then they took
a picture and posted it and made genie
kind of made fun of the idea that like
Oh everyone's gonna be talking about
breaking news
dinner imagine but he was still very
much in her you know in her life she was
listening to him she was getting his
opinion I think towards the end of the
coaching search is when that started to
change a little bit because he wanted
them to hire tyloo and when that sort of
fell apart I think I think that's when
his influence became a little less
prevalent than it had been before now we
talked about Kimball Walker you know
possibly Brockman is a little fired up
Kimball going to the Celtics possibly
but he's a name that stirred up with the
Lakers Jimmy Butler's gonna be available
Kevin Durant still Kawhi Leonard they're
not closing the door on that so what
have you heard of any free agents or
what are the Lakers better yet their
interest well they're their interests
are very guard heavy because that once
they executed that or once they execute
the trade that they're about to execute
there's only one guard on their roster
that has a guaranteed contract for next
year and it's Isaac Banga so so they
that's what they need and that's what
they need to figure out who is gonna be
their point guard I mean I think that's
that's priority number one
Kimbo is one of those potential guys but
I don't know I mean Kemba has said
before that he wants to stay in
Charlotte you know there's different
factors with that Kyrie Irving guy who's
sort of made a mint made amends with
LeBron recently and wants to leave
Boston but I think everyone sort of
thinks that for Irving it'll be a New
York team so you know I mean that's and
that's where we get into talking about
D'Angelo Russell like when you're
talking about the next level of what
point guards are available that he's
he's definitely up there and if he
becomes unrestricted if you know I think
that that could be an option for the
Lakers so Tonya the NBA I played in the
brown James was he was the man and there
are free agents that would go crazy to
play with LeBron James all the way
through his Miami whether it was
Cleveland you wanted a championship you
want to be around greatness now the word
on the streets are we see even with Paul
George guys are now turning down LeBron
James join with ad do you feel like he's
kind of got his zing back he's got his
aura back is he have that same LeBron
James name still or is he still on the
decline
I think that I think that ad playing
with ad and LeBron James would have to
be a really appealing idea to a lot of
guys I when I think of Paul George I
think of it less as he declined LeBron
and more as he declined the Lakers
because why is that well Paul George you
know Paul George went into this the
summer before he got traded he went into
that saying like I want to be a Laker I
want to be a Laker and it I think it
annoyed him that the Lakers weren't
willing to give up what it took to go
get him and and it meant a lot to him to
what from what I was told I meant a lot
to him that the that the Thunder were
that they gave up too you know they gave
up a young guy he turned her net is was
a really good player and I think that
that meant something to him and he just
you know it's the year-long the
year-long recruiting effort that
Oklahoma City got to do they got to show
him what it would be like right he
became close with Russ all those things
so I I really think for him it was more
about that that he did you know he just
didn't like the Lakers didn't go get him
when they could have and and and liked
his time in Oklahoma City so you know I
I would have to think that it would be
appealing but the thing is money really
matters when you're talking about being
able to go out and get free agents and
the Lakers might not have what it takes
money-wise to be able to go get one of
the guys who's gonna command a max
contract depending on what level of max
that is it's the stymie a salary cap is
endlessly confusing but you know that if
they can't then they're just gonna have
to be really smart about how they spend
right now they're slated to have about
23.8 I think million dollars yeah
they're gonna have to be smart about how
they spend that and how they use that to
fill out their also tell you they made
essentially the mistake with Paul George
they didn't go out and trade for them
Kawhi Leonard becomes available
San Antonio asked for the moon they
don't make the move for Kawhi Leonard
did they make the same mistake again do
you see kawatte there's zero chance he
becomes a Laker I don't know about zero
but I would be really surprised if koi
Lenoir became a Laker and so I think
that that that was the lesson that they
learned when they went after Anthony
Davis both times
I had to trade for him first time
they're unsuccessful obviously both
times there was a sense of you have this
has to get done this has to get done
because this is not this cannot be
another year where the Lakers don't
trade for this star who clearly wants to
be here and and miss out on him and then
waste another I mean honestly like if if
you don't get it at least one other star
this year you're gonna waste another
year of LeBrons career Wow Tanya amazing
stuff yeah you got anything any anything
you want to shout out social media any
new stories popping up well you wheeze
wrote a story yesterday about jus what
Jeannie said from the NBA Awards and
just there was first time she'd talked
since all of this craziness started
happening so you can read that at the LA
Times and I'm on Twitter Tonya Ganguly
so is the ice been great it's great
being on with you know me appreciate
having you thanks for bearing with me
Ryan Hollins here at the Rich Eisen show
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app